[Music]
on this monday night torrential rain and
fierce winds batter b.c raging flood
waters and entire city evacuated
motorists rescued by helicopter as
highways are washed away it's mother
nature the effect of extreme weather in
bc and what's in the forecast a first
nations fight with the ontario
government the demand for answers about
what's in the air jason kenney versus
his own party the new challenge
alberta's premier faces
the uk's terror threat level rises
remain utterly vigilant the
investigation into the blast of a
homemade bomb and winging it in nova
scotia a stellar rare sight that has
bird watchers all a flutter
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin on canada's west coast where
torrential prolonged rain has washed out
highways trapped hundreds of people in
their vehicles and forced thousands of
people from their homes all major
highways connecting the lower mainland
to the rest of british columbia are
affected
the extreme rainfall has led to multiple
landslides on highway 7 between agassi
and hope provincial officials say
275 people including 50 children were
stranded for hours between two slides
search and rescue teams were deployed
and canadian armed forces cormorant
helicopters are conducting what they say
will be multiple flights to airlift
people out
a section of the coquihalla highway is
washed out the entire city of merit 7
000 people is under an evacuation order
after flooding caused the wastewater
treatment plant to fail
every major highway leading into
vancouver is cut off by flooding or
mudslides including the trans-canada
highway effectively cutting off road
access to the lower mainland and
vancouver island
last night the agassi fire department
managed to rescue 12 people from their
vehicles which were filling with water
and debris
there's also major flooding in the
greater vancouver area and as the rain
subsides gale force winds are moving in
this barge broke loose and drifted
towards the seawall at sunset beach in
vancouver we begin our coverage tonight
with robin gill who is in abbotsford
about an hour and a half from vancouver
abbotsford is in the heart of british
columbia's farming community but today
it looks more like a fishing village
dawn ellis can barely make out the three
acres of his farm but you know when you
live by a creek you expect one morning
you're going to get up and get your feet
wet that's inevitable but like i said
not like this this is uh
this is something else
all that rain has forced the city to
declare a state of emergency a hundred
homes near the water are on evacuation
alert i've lived here for 68 years
i've not seen this kind of rainfall in
68 in those 68 years
in this part of british columbia at this
point in the season it's known as
november rain but this isn't normal in
the last 24 hours about a hundred
millimeters of rain fell that's a record
and by the end of the day looking at
about 240 millimeters in total
in marriage the city has been deluged
the community of 7 000 people has barely
recovered from the summer fires now
they're on the run from floods the
entire city was ordered to evacuate
after the region's wastewater treatment
plant failed i've been evacuated already
once
from the fires and to be in merit like
it's
and to like have the possibility of it
happening again is kind of kind of crazy
i hate to say it but it's global warming
and um
it's not looking good
scary times to be honest there never
used to be a river there and with the
rain comes landslides closing major
highways around the province and forcing
passengers to sleep in their cars
overnight
a team of disaster experts is working to
get them out by air we have a nice break
in the weather here where the rain is
light the winds are light and we're
removing people from that trapped area
about 20 at a time to a reception center
here in agassi
back in abbotsford the intense rain is
expected to give way to strong winds
which could be a whole new round of
trouble
there isn't much dawn ellis can do well
a lot of cleanup the cleanup is the sad
part because it's going to be one hell
of a mess but just hunker down in this
soggy mess robin gill global news
abbotsford bc
some regions in bc have received more
rain in the past 36 hours than they
usually get in the entire month of
november joining us is global news
meteorologist yvonne shell yvonne what's
caused this extreme rain and what's
coming
donna an incredible storm wreaking havoc
for all areas across the south coast and
it's all courtesy of an atmospheric
river taking aim at the region and that
moisture being drawn in just north of
hawaii now as we get in through the day
today the rain is going to taper off we
have seen rainfall amounts since
saturday afternoon upwards of 270
millimeters near hope agassi in
chilliwack with over 200 and abbotsford
even getting 165 millimeters so far and
counting vancouver harbor and out of the
airport with over 100 millimeters rain
will taper off but now with the passage
of this cold front the big weather story
that we're following for the afternoon
and continuing for the evening winds
we've got wind warnings and special
weather statements extending into the
southern interior anywhere between 70
and then gusts of up to 90 kilometers
per hour grounds so saturated anticipate
power outages as well as fallen trees
across the region and with the cold
front we are going to see that freezing
level drop snow heavy at times for the
mountain passes upwards between 15 and
up to 25 centimeters donna all right
global news meteorologist yvonne shell
on the extreme weather in bc thanks
and ontario first nation has obtained
previously withheld data about air
pollution that forecasts alarming levels
of cancer-causing chemicals in the air
the amdung first nation outside sarnia
is surrounded by industrial plants and
has among the highest levels of air
pollution in the country the people were
told they would be partners in a health
study to see if there was a link between
the environment and their health but it
wasn't until the first nation contacted
global news that the data was shared
carolyn jarvis reports
in amgen first nation air pollution
flares lighting up the sky
and noise disturbances are a regular
occurrence
i don't know what that is what's also
unknown are the health impacts of having
industrial neighbors that are in some
cases mere steps from homes
a health study announced by the
provincial government in 2017 was meant
to help gain understanding
for months amgen has been asking for
some of the data informing it but the
government didn't provide it this is
just the continuation of the canadian
legacy
of putting indigenous people people of
color
at a lower place those reports and those
studies
if they're not sharing it must indicate
that you know there's definite
data to show that there's
issues that there's impacts in
mid-october global news began asking the
government for the data
last week the ministry of the
environment finally shared the documents
with the first nation
they show through computer modeling that
benzene levels a chemical linked to
cancer could reach up to 44 times the
annual level in the industrial area and
also in north amgen
the modeling also predicts sulfur
dioxide levels at or above the annual
level in similar areas there have been a
number of studies that demonstrate
increased level of hospitalizations an
increased level of mortality even with
these higher levels of
so2 on a long term basis
the ministry says it is taking action on
benzene and saw a 50 percent reduction
in levels in north amgen last year and
just last week it put forward a proposed
regulation to rain in sulfur dioxide
from petroleum plants
if approved the regulation will require
companies to share emissions data with
local first nations
the people of amgen only wish that same
rule
would apply to the government we could
be a great partner if we were included
the health study is expected to be
completed next spring
carolyn jarvis global news
toronto
prime minister justin trudeau was in
edmonton today side by side with premier
jason kenney to announce alberta is the
latest province to sign on to a federal
plan to provide 10 a day child care the
3.8 billion dollar agreement will roll
out over the next five years it includes
all types of licensed child care
facilities which was a sticking point
the deal says child care fees will be
cut in half by next year and go down to
ten dollars a day by 2026.
but i am really really pleased to be
here today with premier kenny uh and the
government of alberta to demonstrate
that on the things that matter most to
citizens on the things that matter to
the people that we serve
we can get big things done
about 60 percent of canadian children
are out covered under the deal the
northwest territories nunavut new
brunswick and ontario are the only
holdouts on the national child care
program that was included in april's
federal budget and which the liberals
campaigned heavily on in the last
election
premier kenny's leadership is under
threat by members of his own party more
than one quarter of the united
conservative party constituency
associations are now asking for an early
leadership review global edmonton's
provincial affairs reporter tom vernon
is with me from edmonton tom how serious
a challenge is this for premier kenny
well donna it puts the idea of fighting
for his leadership directly in front of
him what these constituency association
presidents believe they have done is
triggered a clause in the ucp
constitution that requires an early
leadership review and they want it held
before march 1st now premier county has
been pushing back against challenges to
his leadership for months now cutting
deals and kicking people out of his
caucus the most recent deal was cut with
his caucus to hold a leadership review
in april that would be held at an annual
general meeting these presidents say
that's not good enough it would be held
at a time when farmers are busy seeding
and calving and it would only allow
members attending in person to vote they
want one that is held that would allow
every single member of the ucp to be
able to cast a ballot adding to the
intrigue in all this the return of brian
gene a co-founder of the ucp he's
seeking a nomination to run for the
party and his entire plank is to remove
jason kenney as leader
donna more to come on this tom vernon in
edmonton thanks you bet
the federal conservative leader aaron
o'toole is also facing a challenge to
his leadership
under aaron o'toole's leadership the
rift in our party is growing
that's denise batters a conservative
senator from saskatchewan she's launched
a petition calling for an early
leadership review within six months in a
tweet she says o'toole reversed core
policies without input from members in
caucus then lost the election by every
measure matters has 90 days to gather
signatures from 5 percent of party
members in at least five provinces to
force a referendum o'toole isn't
scheduled to face a leadership review
until the party's next annual convention
set for 20-23
in the uk the terror threat has moved up
a notch to severe after a terrorist
incident outside a hospital in liverpool
police say a homemade bomb detonated in
the back of a taxi killing the passenger
the driver managed to jump out and
survive four men are being held and
questioned under the terrorism act as
police investigate our europe bureau
chief crystal gamansing reports
police say it was a homemade bomb that
went off in the back of the taxi the
attack has been labeled terrorism the
passenger was killed in the explosion
but four other men all under the age of
30 are being questioned as a part of the
investigation our inquiries indicate
that an improvised explosive device has
been manufactured and our assumption so
far is that it was built by the
passenger in the taxi
the reason why he then took it to the
women's hospital is unknown
david perry has been identified by
british media as the taxi driver in
security video he can be seen jumping
out of the vehicle he escaped serious
injury what yesterday showed above all
is that the british people will never be
cowed by terrorism we will never give in
to those who seek to divide us with
senseless acts of violence the terror
threat alert in the uk is now at the
second highest level severe it's a
warning to the public that attacks are
highly likely sunday's explosion was the
second alleged terrorist attack in the
u.k in the past month
in october british mp david amos was
stabbed to death while meeting with
constituents
we as a government i as home secretary
continue to work with everyone when it
comes to the security of our country
making sure that we're taking all the
necessary steps required police
identified the man killed in the taxi
blast as 32 year old imad
they say their investigation is still
active and officers are working at
multiple scenes
crystal gomanson global news london
in washington steve bannon former chief
strategist for donald trump has appeared
in court on contempt charges bannon
turned himself in after refusing to
cooperate with the investigation into
the january sixth attack on the u.s
capitol he's not being kept in custody
and will be arraigned on thursday if
convicted bannon faces up to a year in
prison for each charge it's not clear if
the prosecution will sway any of the
other 35 witnesses who've been
subpoenaed but have refused to cooperate
beefing up sanctions against belarus
coming up the eu's next move as the
migrant crisis deepens plus from happy
feet to aching feet one penguin's
journey crossing continents
[Music]
the air over india's capital is so toxic
schools and construction sites have been
shut down for four days the country's
supreme court also ordered offices to
close so people can work from home the
amount of hazardous particulate matter
in the air is six times the global
safety level coal-fired power plants are
one of the main reasons for the heavy
smog along with farmers burning crop
waste
the european union is stepping up
sanctions on belarus in response to an
escalating migrant crisis on the border
with poland the sanctions target a
number of individuals and entities for
facilitating illegal border crossings
into the eu the eu accuses president
alexander lukashenka of pushing migrants
towards its borders to undermine
security a charge he denies most of the
migrants caught in the middle of the
diplomatic standoff are now stranded
along the border in freezing conditions
with limited food and shelter
and the head of nato has warned russia
about its military buildup along the
border with ukraine
know that russia has been willing to use
these types of military capabilities
before
to conduct aggressive actions against
ukraine
yen stoltenberg called on russia to be
transparent about its activities and to
prevent any further escalation of
tensions the ukrainian government claims
nearly one hundred thousand russian
troops are amassing across the border it
says its own military forces are ready
to repel any possible acts of russian
aggression the kremlin dismissed claims
it's planning any sort of attack as
inflammatory
ahead how the supply crunch is holding
back the recovery of some small
businesses
supply chain issues are affecting
businesses of all kinds especially
retailers who rely on imports zan
gaviola explains big companies tend to
be more flexible and resilient than
small and medium-sized ones who are
worried about what the holiday season
might bring
november was nerve-racking for the dutch
growers garden center in saskatoon some
of their holiday stock was on board a
cargo ship that lost 109 containers off
the coast of bc followed by a fire on
board now their situation was unusual
but their predicament waiting on holiday
merchandise was not retailers across
canada have been literally sitting on
pins and needles
waiting since august
when are my shipments going to come how
much are they going to cost
as a medium-sized business with a
handful of locations the garden center
has been able to pivot to local goods
but even that strategy has its limits
when it comes closer to christmas you're
going to start to see the shelves
getting thinner and thinner the supply
chain crisis impacts goods made overseas
that come to our shores by boat there
are issues at every link in the chain
from manufacturing to shipping and
trucking larger businesses and
multinationals with deep pockets have
more options than small and medium-sized
companies such as chartering their own
cargo ships and even buying part of a
shipping port smaller firms don't have
the same bargaining or purchasing power
dan kelly represents the interests of 95
000 independently owned businesses
across the country the toll is still
being felt from nearly two years of
pandemic restrictions while big box
rivals were allowed to stay open and
reap record profits
one in six small businesses will
permanently close their doors as a
result of the damage that they've
sustained during the pandemic
independent business owner julie fass
says only the most nimble can survive
ever changing coveted rules labor
shortages cost increases and the supply
crunch it really has been
miraculous in some ways that we can keep
pivoting her shop sells things that
people like to touch and smell before
buying now she hopes people will shop
local and support homegrown
entrepreneurs trying to recover
it does take a bit of an effort
but i know
everyone wants to see these small
businesses succeed rather than flocking
to big box stores or amazon even if it
means more effort and more money ann
gaviola global news toronto
next the odyssey of a rare eagle from
russia to nova scotia
this little penguin is a long way from
home it's a natalie penguin and was
found on a new zealand beach at least 3
000 kilometers away from antarctica its
natural habitat locals named it pingu
and after some rehabilitation and food
it was released back onto a beach just
east of christchurch new zealand it's
only the third adelie penguin that has
been found on new zealand's shores
in nova scotia bird watchers have been
captivated by an eagle that's normally
spotted half a world away it's a
steller's sea eagle a rare arctic bird
that can be bigger than a bald eagle and
is typically seen in china japan and
korea and the east coast of russia as
ross lord explains bird watchers are
flocking to catch a glimpse of this
winged wanderer
so the white bear is on what we call the
leading edge of the wing when diane
leblanc found out this bird had been
seen in nova scotia she took flight out
the door the first immediate response
when you hear like that there's a
stellar sea eagle in nova scotia is a
heart-pounding
bird emergency feeling where you feel
like you have to just move as quickly as
you can she drove immediately to the
community of falmouth an hour away
there she joined an exclusive group of
bird lovers seeing and photographing the
steller's sea eagle a magnificent bird
of prey with a different appearance than
the more commonly seen bald eagle we
could definitely see the markings those
that bright orange bill and the white on
the sides of the of the wings
the shoulders with a wingspan of two and
a half meters and weighing up to nine
kilograms the stellars is the largest
eagle in the world as heavy as an
average one-year-old boy it seems the
eagle has been away from home for a long
time
seen in alaska last august possibly
swooping down over south texas this
spring
then turning up in quebec and de
brunswick in july before causing a stir
in nova scotia this month
that's almost 11 000 kilometers from its
native range in china and other parts of
asia and europe it's somewhere in
between extremely unusual and one in a
million
the thing about you know when when a
bird like this shows up
it certainly was not on
a lot of people's uh list so to speak as
the next super rare thing to show up the
stuller's eagle is declining in number
wildlife groups consider it a vulnerable
species number 353 for diane leblanc the
stellars is a precious entry in her life
list record of confirmed bird sightings
she hopes the eagle can make a life for
itself in north america or even better
finds a way to fly back home
ross lord global news windsor nova
scotia
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is another bird it's a common
nighthawk in regina once abundant it is
now threatened we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye
[Music]